Transcription: Bénédicte Mertz
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd’hui, j’aimerais proposer
une chose :
qu’on cesse de parler de l’effondrement
et plutôt qu’on évoque ensemble
ce qu’on peut faire concrètement ensemble.
Nous sommes face à un problème
d’envergure, un problème d’environnement.
Et l’environnement c’est plein
de choses, plein de facteurs.
D’abord, des facteurs physiques,
comme le climat, la géologie.
Ou encore des facteurs biologiques,
les êtres humains, la faune, la flore.
Et tout ça pose un réel problème.
Et c’est un tel problème que, déjà en 92,
au Sommet de la Terre à Rio de Janeiro,
178 pays,
soit la quasi-totalité de la planète,
se réunissent pour définir ensemble
ce que serait le développement durable
et en quoi ça consisterait.
À l’évidence, le développement durable
cherche encore sa voie,
peine à trouver sa place,
trente ans plus tard.
Alors, sur quoi repose véritablement
l’avènement du développement durable ?
Selon moi, sur deux choses.
D’abord, l’intelligence,
individuelle et collective,
et ensuite,
la transformation sincère de nos modèles.
Et ces deux fondements-là reposent
eux-mêmes sur trois autres contreparties.
La première, la bonne compréhension
de notre monde.
L’éducation, donc.
La deuxième, c’est la lutte
contre le carbo-fascisme.
Je reviendrai sur ce terme.
Et enfin, la prise en compte réelle
et effective des générations futures.
Alors, commençons par l’éducation.
L’éducation, elle fait partie de nos vies.
On la connaît depuis toujours
et pourtant, elle est mise à mal.
On la critique, elle n'est pas suffisante,
pas assez qualitative.
L’étymologie suggère que
l’éducation, c’est sortir hors de lui
ce qu’un individu possède en lui.
Alors, c’est très beau, mais
ça ne vous dit pas grand-chose.
Je vous propose de déconstruire cette
notion d'éducation pour mieux la saisir.
Voici une méthode très simple,
que j’utilise avec les étudiants
et en entreprise.
Je l’ai appelée la méthode IES
en trois lettres I, E, S.
Informer, expliquer et sensibiliser.
Informer, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Informer, c'est transmettre les bonnes
données, les chiffres, les connaissances.
Expliquer, c’est dire pourquoi
ces données existent à la base.
Ce qui s’est passé,
pourquoi est-ce qu’on en est là.
En somme, informer, c'est permettre
à l'autre de savoir.
Mais expliquer,
c’est permettre à l’autre de comprendre.
Deux phénomènes cognitifs
complètement différents.
Ce qui m’amène d’ailleurs à mon troisième
point : sensibiliser.
Sensibiliser,
c’est littéralement rendre sensible.
C’est un mot d’ailleurs
qui vient du jargon médical
qui a trait au fait de faire réagir
un organe à une stimulation.
En d’autres termes, si on veut,
sensibiliser,
c’est créer les bonnes dispositions
pour susciter l’envie viscérale d’agir.
Alors, très bien.
Mais concrètement ?
Je pense que pour sensibiliser,
il n’y a rien de mieux que se rapprocher,
et de toucher l’objet en question.
Je vous donne un exemple.
La journée Défense et citoyenneté,
qui prépare notre jeunesse à la défense
hypothétique de notre nation.
Moi, je me dis que si une telle journée
existe aujourd’hui,
il serait pertinent de créer un cursus
nommé compréhension environnementale,
car il me semble que les enfants
n’ont pas besoin
de savoir tenir des armes.
Par contre, on a besoin d’enfants qui
comprennent leur environnement,
leur habitat.
Parce que comment respecter
ce qu’on ne comprend pas ?
L’éducation, pour moi, est
beaucoup plus palpable,
et beaucoup plus efficace
quand on la déconstruit.
Informer, expliquer, sensibiliser.
Passons à la deuxième contrepartie,
la lutte contre le carbo-fascisme.
Alors, le carbo-fascisme,
c’est une notion assez drôle,
qui a été récemment habilitée
par Jean-Baptiste Fressoz.
Pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas,
c’est un historien des sciences
et des techniques.
Et elle désigne une doctrine
visant à démobiliser,
décourager les personnes
à protéger l’environnement.
En fait, les carbo-fascistes sont un peu
des défenseurs acharnés du carbone,
et en fait, on en connaît plein,
des illustres même.
Scott Morrisson, Australie,
Boris Johnson en Grande-Bretagne,
Rodrigo Duarte aux Philippines ou encore
l’ancien président américain Donald Trump,
qui lui, et c’est assez marrant,
a fourni tous les efforts possibles pour
décrédibiliser le développement durable.
Mais cela dit, il a assuré ses terrains
de golf contre la montée des eaux.
Carbo-fascisme.
Deuxième exemple, Jair Bolsonaro,
président brésilien,
autre carbo-fasciste illustre.
Lui n’a pas fait dans la dentelle.
Démantèlement, carrément, du ministère
de l’Environnement.
Création d’autoroutes, boum,
en plein cœur de l’Amazonie.
Suppression de leurs droits et de leur
territoire aux communautés autochtones.
Dernier exemple, en 2019,
à la Chambre des représentants américaine,
la démocrate A. Ocasio-Cortez auditionne
des chercheurs ayant travaillé pour Exxon.
Exxon, une des plus grandes
entreprises pétrolières au monde.
Et ces deux chercheurs, durant cette
audition, admettent une chose.
C’est qu’en 1980, ils avaient prédit que
quarante ans plus tard, soit maintenant,
s’ils continuaient leurs activités
de la même manière,
la concentration atmosphérique en CO2
atteindrait 445 parties par million,
et que la température
augmenterait d’un pourcent.
En l’occurrence, c’est ce
qu’il se passe aujourd’hui.
Donc, ils savaient, ils savaient et ils
n’ont rien fait, ils ont continué.
À vrai dire, si, ils ont fait
une chose supplémentaire.
Pendant 30 ans, ils ont dépensé une
trentaine de millions de dollars en lobby,
pour promouvoir le déni climatique.
Alors pourquoi ces personnes
se donnent autant de mal
pour frayer un beau chemin au carbone ?
C’est peut-être parce qu’en fait, ils ont
plus à gagner avec une planète malade.
Il faut comprendre une chose,
et c’est purement mathématique,
c’est que les contextes de crise
sont nécessaires à la croissance.
L’opportunité capitaliste réside dans
cet équilibre entre ces deux extrêmes :
crise et croissance.
On dit d'ailleurs en finance que les
arbres ne montent pas jusqu'au ciel.
C’est comme une plante
qui ne pousse plus.
On la coupe en fuseau et elle repart.
On crée un relais de croissance.
En fait la finance, elle fait
exactement la même chose.
Chaque crise, pour les carbo-fascistes,
est une opportunité,
c’est bon pour les affaires.
Une pandémie mondiale provoquée
par une déforestation de masse
et l’hyper-artificialisation des sols.
Une île du Pacifique
à la merci d’une marée de pétrole,
ou encore,
une explosion avec des tonnes de nitrate
d’ammonium sur le port d’une ville monde.
Tout ça, tout ça, sont des opportunités.
Sauf que ça fragilise
notre équilibre déjà précaire.
Parce que l’effondrement,
ça n’est pas comme dans les films,
ça n’est pas un énorme boum
qui vient et plus rien.
Non, l’effondrement,
c’est la succession de crises
qui viennent fragiliser
et fragiliser encore.
Rome. C’est parce que Rome souffrait
déjà de nombreux fléaux :
expansion à outrance,
dégradation de l’environnement menant à
de mauvaises récoltes et donc des famines,
organisation dysfonctionnelle aussi,
que les Wisigoths, puis les Vandales
les ont expédiés en moins d’un siècle.
Je pense qu’il faut combattre
le carbo-fascisme,
de la même manière
qu’on lutte pour l’environnement,
car c’est une condition sine qua non.
J’ai appris, ces dernières années,
à mes dépens,
qu’il ne s’agissait pas seulement
de faire le bien.
Il s’agit aussi parfois, et même
souvent, de défaire le mal.
Et il faut le faire avec toute la
détermination, toute la fermeté,
et évidemment  avec tout
l’amour pour l’autre qu’on peut,
aussi différent cet autre soit-il.
Alors voici pour la partie
déprimante de ce TED.
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que
notre société, nos sociétés,
ont la capacité de repousser,
voire d’empêcher,
un effondrement, une catastrophe.
L'histoire de l'humanité tout entière est
rythmée par notre capacité à faire mieux
grâce aux techniques que nous inventons.
Et on peut remonter à la révolution
cognitive en moins 70 000
avec l’arrivée
des premiers outils complexes,
comme le propulseur,
qui permet la chasse de plus gros gibiers,
ou encore l’aiguille à chat,
qui permet les débuts de la couture
et donc la protection contre le froid.
On peut nommer l'avènement
de la métallurgie.
On peut nommer la maîtrise du feu.
Et puis viendront après la vapeur,
le pétrole, l’électricité, le nucléaire,
et puis le progrès numérique.
Là résident toutes nos technologies
les plus prodigieuses,
celles qui nous ont permis par le passé,
et celles qui permettent encore,
de nous prémunir de la décadence, à
condition de les utiliser avec pertinence.
Alors, on comprend maintenant que
l’écologie, face à ce défi monumental,
est incontestablement nécessaire.
Sauf que l’écologie, en ce moment,
est mise à mal.
Elle a besoin de se renforcer,
et elle peut le faire
en se recentrant autour de trois valeurs
qui manquent souvent à l’appel.
L’union, la vision et la technologie.
Commençons par l'union.
L’union, toute stratégie long terme
repose sur l’union et l’esprit d’équipe.
Or, depuis quelques années,
l’écologie avance en ordre dispersé,
et je ne parle même pas des oppositions
entre ceux pour l’environnement,
ceux qui ne s’y intéressent pas.
Il n’y a qu’à voir
les désaccords entre les personnes
qui sont pour l’environnement elles-mêmes.
Entre les croissants qui veulent
de la durabilité soluble
dans une économie de marché,
les décroissants qui pensent
que la croissance même
est le fléau de l’environnement,
et puis comptons le nombre de
partis politiques écologistes en France.
C’est à s’y perdre.
Ils ont tous des idées aux antipodes
les unes des autres.
Sauf que trop d'idées, ça tue l'idéologie.
L’union est fondatrice.
Elle amplifie l'écho.
Elle repose sur ce -
Elle est un bouclier puissant qui repose
sur l'impitoyable loi du nombre.
Au cinquième siècle à Athènes,
c’est d’ailleurs comme ça que
Clisthène arrive à contrer Isagoras,
qui lui souhaite rétablir l’oligarchie.
Il va s’unir au peuple
et grâce à cette union,
il va créer ce à quoi nous tenons tous :
la démocratie.
Toute chose durable se base sur l’union.
Alors une fois qu’on a l’union,
passons à la vision.
Parce que, concrètement,
quel est l’objectif de l’écologie ?
Je veux dire, hormis elle-même.
Qu’est-ce qu’elle propose
une fois la planète sauvée ?
À quoi ça ressemble « demain »
dans un futur écologique ?
Selon moi, l’écologie manque aujourd’hui
d’un avenir réaliste et réalisable à voir.
Et c'est là son deuxième enjeu.
Qu’est-ce qu’une vision ?
Une vision, c’est avoir des idées
plus grandes que l’immédiat.
C'est permettre à l'espoir d'être
une alternative possible.
Et alors, comment on la construit
quand le temps presse ?
Deux petites techniques :
la première, c’est se mettre d’accord,
identifier les missions prioritaires sur
lesquelles on est collectivement d’accord.
Ensuite, paver le chemin de petites
victoires pour motiver,
et pas seulement des prospectives
à 50, 70, 100 ans.
Je me suis amusée à analyser
quelques grandes visions de ce monde,
et c’est marrant, elles tournent
souvent autour de trois axes.
D’abord, l’adhésion.
Une grande vision prend en compte
les craintes, les considérations,
les espoirs des personnes qu’elle adresse.
La deuxième chose,
ce sont les ressources,
il faut être pragmatique.
Toutes les grandes visions qui ont abouti
bénéficiaient d’un cadre institutionnel
fiable, fort et de ressources financières
pour être déployées.
Enfin, la représentativité,
la fameuse et la belle inclusion.
Une grande vision, ça sait relier,
marier les intérêts multiples.
Une fois qu’on a la vision,
il ne reste plus qu’à dérouler.
Mais, comment est-ce qu’on crée
quelque chose qui n’existe pas encore ?
Eh bien, c’est là, tout simplement,
l’enjeu de la technologie.
Technologie / Écologie.
C'est un énorme débat.
Ces deux mots ne vont pas ensemble
et pourtant, je n’en suis pas sûre.
Alors, c’est vrai, le côté métallurgique
très industriel de la technologie,
jure avec le fantasme vert
et édénien de l’écologie.
Et dans l’imaginaire collectif,
la technologie,
c’est l’apanage des grands pollueurs.
Or, à mon sens, elle n’est leur propriété
que tacite en fait,
parce que personne d’autre
ne s’est manifesté pour l’utiliser.
Je pense sincèrement que la technologie,
au même titre que la planète,
est un bien commun à tous
et à toutes les idéologies.
Aujourd’hui, le deuxième problème de ces
deux notions écologie, technologie,
c’est qu’elles se prennent toutes
les deux pour le nouveau Dieu.
Elles essayent d’instaurer
en elles-mêmes des dogmes.
Mais on sait aujourd’hui
aucun Dieu unique n’accepte,
ne supporte, la présence d’un autre.
Donc, je pense que pour éviter cet écueil,
il faut les ramener à ce qu’elles
sont à la base : deux sciences.
Écologie, science de l’habitat.
Technologie, science de la technique.
C’est-à-dire la science numérique qui
rend possible la science du climat,
grâce à la modélisation informatique
des données climatiques.
Elle rend possible la
paléoclimatologie, passionnante.
Elle rend possible la réduction ou
l’agrandissement d’échelles de modèle.
Elle rend possible le futur.
Je pense que -
Je pense une dernière chose.
Je pense aussi pourquoi on a nommé
cette chose de tech for good.
Vous savez, cette chose un peu à part,
un peu en marge, qui est là ?
En fait, c’est la meilleure façon
d’insinuer que la norme,
c’est la tech for bad.
Encore une fois, tout est fait pour
que la technologie méprise l’écologie,
et inversement.
Je pense sincèrement que l’écologie
a besoin de la technologie.
Je pense que la technologie est
l’amie insoupçonnée de l’écologie.
Je pense que la technologie
nous permet d’espérer, de concilier
monde moderne et harmonie avec la nature.
Et on a déjà plein d’exemples,
ne serait-ce qu’en France.
Aujourd’hui, en France,
on sait transformer,
fossiliser des déchets ménagers
non recyclables,
pour construire des routes,
en faire du granulat.
On sait utiliser la technologie pour
booster l’immunité des plantes,
grâce à des flash UV, et empêcher
l’utilisation de tonnes de fongicides.
Demain, les algorithmes pourraient
repenser un système financier
complètement différent,
qui nous permettrait d’avoir une société
plus distributive, plus équitable,
où personne ne manque de quoi que ce soit.
Voici les trois grands travaux
pour moi de l'écologie.
L’union, la vision et la technologie.
Et pour conclure,
j’aimerais citer Deleuze.
Deleuze disait qu’il fallait
faire attention
de ne pas vivre le rêve des autres.
Ceux qui occupent l’espace.
Et qu’il fallait avoir le courage de
vivre ses propres rêves, de les nommer.
Alors voilà, moi, je nomme
mon rêve courageux à moi,
celui qu’on puisse vivre tous ensemble,
avec beaucoup d’harmonie.
Et aussi naïf que ce soit,
je vais le redire.
Mon rêve à moi, c’est qu’on
puisse vivre tous ensemble,
avec harmonie, durabilité,
et encore mieux :
c’est que les prochaines générations
puissent le faire aussi.
Celles qu’on ne connaît pas encore
et qu’on ne connaîtra jamais,
parce que nous ne serons plus là.
Parce que ça aurait un avantage
non négligeable et très beau,
celui d’être peut-être un jour
de bons ancêtres,
et peut-être même les grands ancêtres,
parce que l’avenir a besoin de nous.
Merci beaucoup.